what are the things that I'm drawing
inspiration from at current Mr Beast on
personal brand side here you've got
Warren Buffett on the investment side
and then Elon from Big vision and I feel
like those three things are probably
where I draw the most inspiration from
in terms of like our day to day and what
we're trying to do I mean I admire Elon
a lot just his ability to see vision and
connect to a larger Mission he's been
able to masterfully do that every single
company's been a part of and his track
record's incredibly impressive
he obviously has flaws like all of us do
but I think he also has been really good
about like owning his flaws on the
totally other side of the coin I think I
admire what like Mr Beast has done from
a personal branding perspective I am
inspired by Warren Buffett I am because
of the long-term mentality he has and he
built Berkshire Hathaway he's like a
beautiful life story of like just
believing in the power of compounding
and patience